over the next month some clark county
school district students and staff
will prepare to head back to the
classroom today
superintendent dr jesus jara gave the
2021 state of the school's address
discussing the return
of in-person learning and a wide variety
of topics
kate houston shares how the district
plans to move forward once kids are back
in class
the covet 19 pandemic has changed nearly
every aspect of the way students are
taught
with that in mind dr jarrah says once
students are back in the classroom they
should not be relying on the same
education model from before the pandemic
in his address dr jarrah touched on a
variety of topics including mental
health resources for students and
educators
teacher recruitment and the importance
of looking at new ways to educate
students
pre-covered school was working
for some kids it wasn't working for all
kids
although distance learning was
challenging for many dr jarrah notes
that some kids
did excel because they were going at
their own pace moving forward he wants
to look at ways that provide more choice
for students and their families
why do you have to sit in biology for
180 days
if you know the content and you can
demonstrate
that you know the content in order to
move forward with this momentum
dr jara says it's crucial for students
to continue to use the devices provided
by the district
we can't put all of this technology in
the hands of our of our educators and
our children and then take that away
because we can't continue to invest when
we come back face to face
you know then we're still going to be
using those tools
the clark county school district plans
to reach out to families to get input
from both parents and students
on what changes they want to see for the
2021-2022 school year
kate houston 8 news now